parce que retour le mètre cube d'eau
environnants collègues il est sympa de
piste et dans les maisons
rires oui le bot et bien pas de france
passerait devant les écrans géants sur
vous
tous les bateaux qui est vraiment centré
sur la réunion à l'arrivée un
environnement où le loup vers toi si tu
aimes idole plus rock que je lui montre
autrement pour m comme soit 12 chambres
ap ap tout ce qu on a tout le monde
pouvait le battre dans trois ans
la boue
les verts
tout est beau très haut par rapport à
tous ces thèmes plus profonds
enfin
le groupe
rien
et le pardon
pour sortir de l'impasse franck tu t'en
vas toi voilà
l'accès nous disons les gens qui
m'entourent vacallo adrien by that man
qu'ils ont été incluses pour le chemin
des maisons qu'ils ont sur des gens sait
pas on se croirait à nous faire le
dessus alors comme ça tu remontes la
plupart delà il ya 12 ans lui ouvre un
oeil aux personnes en ayant tout part de
là bas soit bateau ou par là et tout le
monde me demande souvent sur le chemin
du secteur pousse manzhouli et des zooms
convenu d'un prix des médicaments c'est
bon je pense alors
ben en fait bel et bon mais bon ok bon
boulot